[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bonsoir à tous bienvenue dans le 7-8
journal sur tv 78 nous sommes le mardi à
27 mars tout de suite les titres de
cette édition terre de versailles c'est
le nom de ce nouveau quartier le
neuvième de la cité royale qui va voir
le jour à l'horizon 2026 et les contours
du projet viennent d'être dévoilées un
programme de 5 144 logements pour
accueillir 2500 habitants et un quartier
résolument tourné vers le bien-être et
la nature ils protestent contre la loi
de programmation de la justice avocats
magistrats et personnels du tribunal de
grande instance de versailles sont en
grève totale jusqu'à vendredi un
mouvement reconduit depuis la semaine
dernière nous en parlons avec michel
beso représentant cfdt au comité
technique du ministère de la justice
et puis notre portrait de la semaine est
consacré un sportif saint quentinois
passé notamment par le sky rugby à
fabien vitse a connu récemment sa
première sélection en équipe de france
des moins de 18 ans elle nous l'avons
rencontrée et nous évoquerons également
dans ce journal la finale du deuxième
concours de l'éloquence de l'université
versailles saint quentin en yvelines
avec notre invité anthony la mode qui
est le fondateur de ce concours jusqu'à
dimanche c'est la semaine de l'industrie
focus cette année sur l'industrie
connectés c'est dans ce cadre qu'il
irait lundi bruno le maire s'est rendu à
maurepas accompagné d'une quinzaine de
lycéens 17 marques le ministre de
l'économie et des finances a lancé cet
événement national dans une entreprise
de la ville
elle est spécialisée dans le design des
grands noms de l'automobile des bateaux
et de l'aviation
en tout une dizaine
d'événements se déroule dans les
yvelines dans le cadre de cette semaine
de l'industrie
un neuvième quartier pour versailles et
le nouvel espace va voir le jour dans
une zone située entre le château et la
ville de saint cyr l'école
un projet baptisé terre de versailles
qui prévoit la construction de 500 avec
44 logements une idée est directrice
autour de ce projet la zénitude
explications avec mickaël landreau le
bien-être et la nature au coeur d'un
nouveau quartier de versailles la ville
et les collaborateurs du projet ont
dévoilé à paris les contours du futur
site un espace construit sur une
ancienne friche militaire située au fond
du parc du château qui pour accueillir
2500 nouveaux habitants dans 5 144
logements
l'ensemble du site aura pour seul mot
d'ordre la zénitude le quartier tout un
écosystème avec à une halte gourmande
100% bio une et des maisons
participative un hôtel d'un nouveau
on apprendra à vivre en harmonie avec la
nature avec des espaces de méditation de
jeunes un centre équestre dans lequel on
travaille sur le langage des chevaux une
plaine des sports
autre particularité de cette cité jardin
les voitures seront presque invisible
dans l'espace de vingt hectares
seule une rue principale sera ouverte à
la circulation les parkings sont tous
enterrés
y compris pour les maisons individuelles
ce qui produit des espaces paysagers et
des rues totalement libre de la
circulation attendu avec ce neuvième
quartier de versailles son concept
idéaliste la municipalité veut inspirer
les villes du futur la ville moderne
c'est la ville écologique c'est la ville
nature et versa il se veut être au
niveau national mais aussi mondiale un
démonstrateur en ce domaine notre
histoire le permet les histoires de
versailles avait hérité de la pensée de
le nôtre qui est la référence dans le
monde sur le paysage et donc ancré dans
cette histoire on veut montrer que verse
ars encore à pointe de la réflexion
coût total pour cette opération 56
millions d'euros la livraison définitive
du site est programmée à l'horizon 2026
on reste à versailles où les avocats
magistrats et personnels du tribunal de
grande instance sont en grève totale
jusqu'à vendredi un mouvement pour
protester contre la loi de programmation
de la justice allait passer devant le
conseil d'état la semaine dernière
bonsoir michel besson ont selon ce
représentant cfdt au comité technique du
ministère de la justice on va parler
dans un instant des motifs d'opposition
à ce projet de loi voulu par la garde
des sceaux nicole belloubet une grève
totale à à versailles ce que c'est du
jamais vu
alors pour le moment seuls les avocats
sont en grève totale
mais les magistrats et fonctionnaires
sont mobilisés quand ce projet de loi
est une grève totale il y en a déjà eu
une en novembre 2000 pendant une semaine
le tribunal ne fonctionnait plus la
grève totale des avocats qu'est ce que
ça veut dire concrètement sur le déroulé
normal au tribunal
grande instance quel impact filmant sa
seconde tout simplement c'est que quand
les avocats demandent le renvoi d'une
affaire il est en principe accordés et
les affaires ne passe pas devant un
tribunal
seul tout ce qui concerne la sécurité
publique la détention parce quand même
au tribunal il y à des permanences un
tribunal fonctionne comme un hôpital
donc il y à des permanences pour des
mesures de sécurité
est-ce que du coup ce mouvement génère
des tensions ou pas du tout alors pas du
tout en tout cas pas en interne puisque
les avocats magistrats et personnels
sont mobilisés ensemble ça c'est unique
cette mobilisation commune des
professionnels de justice contre ce
projet de loi
donc il n'y a pas de tensions en interne
par contre il y à des désagréments mais
c'est le but d'une grève
les procès sont reportés alors si on
rentre dans le détail de ce projet de
loi cinq volets et des principales
annonces faites notamment
l'expérimentation d'un tribunal criminel
à la place des cours d'assises pour
juger certains crimes les viols par
exemple l'idée est de désengorger les
cours d'assises saturé autre annonce est
la fusion des tribunaux d'instance et de
grande instance ont redessiné pour
autant la carte judiciaire pourquoi ça
coince de votre côté pour prendre
l'exemple de la justice au quotidien les
tribunaux d'instance
il y en a cinq dans le département des
yvelines nous ne savons pas à l'heure
actuelle dans le cadre du projet de loi
ce qu'il va devenir exactement du
contentieux de proximité puisque tout
est regroupé sera regroupé au chef lieu
du département très bien le grande
instance et il appartiendra
selon le projet de loi mais ça sera
défini par voie d'ordonnancé
encore une fois on se passe du parlement
par voie d'ordonnancé
les modalités de tel ou tel contentieux
à rambouillet à poissy à mantoue à saint
germain en tout cas ça a été annoncé par
nicole belloubet a priori aucun tribunal
ne sera fermée alors vous estime
également ne pas avoir été assez associé
finalement à la concertation sur sur ce
projet de loi pour préparer ce projet de
loi tout à fait
un ministre a lancé ce qu'elle appelle
les chantiers de la justice il y a eu
des auditions et des rapports ont été
déposées la ministre a reçu les
organisations syndicales en bilatéral
dans son dans son bureau
mais il n'y a eu aucune réunion de
concertation dans les instances
réglementaires prévues pour au sein du
ministère de la justice
avant le dépôt du projet au conseil
d'état c'est à dire qu'on a déposé le
projet au conseil d'état sans avoir
réellement concerté l'ensemble des
représentants des personnels injustement
qu'auriez vous voulu dire à la ministre
qu'elle proposition vous juger et
finalement nécessaire et qui doit qui
doivent être intégrées dans ce projet de
loi mais pour les personnels la
connaissance des textes pour savoir
comment vont être organisées les
juridictions après demain nous ne le
savons pas et pour tout à chacun pour
les justiciables
on ne sait pas si ils devront aller à
poissy à saint germain ou à versailles
pour certains contentieux et du coup
quels sont les objectifs de la grève on
a parlé aussi d'une grève totale des
avocats on précise qu'il ya plusieurs
mouvements un peu partout en france ce
n'est pas qu'à versailles vous vous
demandez à être associés davantage au
projet à la rédaction du projet oui on
demande à avoir plus de précisions sur
l'organisation judiciaire
on demande alors pour ce qui est de la
cfdt à ce que des pans du projet
disparaissent nous notons une certaine
privatisation de la justice
certains contentieux sont totalement
privatisée pour faire des économies et
pour renvoyer le justiciable ailleurs
que dans nos juridictions
or ça va coûter beaucoup plus cher pour
le justiciable certes le ministère de la
justice fera des économies que vous en
avez parlé le gouvernement pourrait
faire appel aux ordonnances pour faire
face et ce projet de loi comme en
réaction vous avez face le sommes
totalement opposés ça devient une manie
dans ce sens au gouvernement de passer
outre la vraie discussion parlementaire
et nous savons que tout se construit
tout peut se construire par voie
d'amendement qu'il peut y avoir une
vraie discussion à l'assemblée nationale
et au sénat et qu'une partie de
l'organisation judiciaire va passer
outre cette discussion et du coup quelle
suite donner au mouvement
il prend de l'ampleur
à titre d'exemple il y aura une
manifestation à versailles vendredi
prochain vendredi midi des assemblées
générales sont prévues aussi dans nos
juridictions et si la ministre ne veut
pas bouger à un grand rassemblement
national est prévu début avril à paris
si on revient sur votre mobilisation
elle remonte déjà à début 2018 il ya eu
plusieurs
plusieurs actions menées notamment en
février oui le 15 février il y avait
déjà une première mobilisation à
versailles comme france entière nous
avons noté qu'il y a quand même quelques
juridictions en france qui se radicalise
pardonnez moi cette expression mais dont
la contestation devient de plus en plus
dur car les personnels comme les
justiciables n'accepte pas de faire 50
80 km pourrait me voir régler un litige
merci à michel destot d'avoir été avec
nous merci et je rappelle que vous êtes
représentant cfdt au comité technique du
ministère de la justice merci d'être
venu de parler de ce sujet de cette
grève des avocats magistrats et du
personnel au tribunal de grande instance
de versailles environnement ils ont
enlevé et mégots de cigarettes canettes
et bouteilles lors de cette opération
depuis six ans elle est membre du
conseil municipal des jeunes de bois
d'arcy ramasse les déchets une action de
nettoyage que ces enfants âgés de 11 à
14 ans ont réalisé ce week-end reportage
de mélanie poker et de nicolas landry
kahn est un fin trait plein de lego
mais c'est sûr que les mégots que vous
trouvez cet arrêt que les arrêtent de
filmer comme flora les élus du conseil
municipal des jeunes de bois d'arcy
chasser les déchets mal je t'ai général
on trouve beaucoup de cigarettes au bord
des trottoirs alors que des fois il ya
des popeye à des poubelles mais juste de
mètres plus loin
donc c'est pas compliqué de juste avoir
de sega dans la main et de la jeter de
mètres plus loin
le htv au bord des trottoirs ce jour là
ils sont 20 à avoir enfilé gants et
mentaux dans le quartier du vieux bourg
nettoyons notre ville a été lancé il y a
6 ont même s'il ya une nette
amélioration par rapport à certains à
certaines années il ya certes un certain
endroit qui sont plus sales que d'autres
donc ils se rendent vraiment compte de
l'incivilité des de certaines personnes
dans leur ville et ça les touche
particulièrement
après deux heures d'activité ils ont
rempli une vingtaine de sacs poubelles
qu'ils ont aussi trivier le conseil des
jeunes veut aller plus loin
il travaille à la mise en place d'une
charte écocitoyenne avec les écoles de
la ville
c'est demain mercredi la finale du
deuxième concours d'éloquence de
l'université versailles saint quentin en
yvelines elle se tient à partir de 20
heures amphi diderot bâtiment d'alembert
à guyancourt on en parle avec anthony la
mode 2d soir bonsoir
vous êtes le fondateur de ce concours
d'éloquence de l'ue vs qu ancien
étudiant de de l'université alors finale
de cette deuxième édition demain
pourquoi avoir eu envie de créer un
concours d'éloquence a lu vs qu alors
pour la petite histoire le concours a eu
lieu il ya trois ans pour la première
fois les 8es de mantes-la-jolie d'accord
en tant qu'étudiant glisse-t-il écoles
d'ingénieurs de l'université de
versailles saint quentin on organisait
le concours en interne à l'école
d'ingénieurs et l'an passé on a décidé
de faire ça en plus grand pour tous les
étudiants de l'université 90 candidats
l'an passé 7 années 60
donc c'est un projet qui perdure quels
sont les objectifs d'un tel concours à
l'objectif de ce concours c'est aussi de
montrer aux étudiants qu'il n'ya pas que
les études et qu'on peut même si les
scientifiques utiliser le langage qui
peut nous servir dans nos métiers futur
c'est le premier intérêt le deuxième
intérêt c'est aussi de se faire
rencontrer les gens beaucoup d'étudiants
se rendent pas compte qu'ils
appartiennent
une grande université avec beaucoup de
filières différentes les personnels
également qu'ils ont rencontré des
étudiants d'autres filières
c'est surtout un échange derrière ce
concours on parle juste de
l'organisation il ya plusieurs anciens
du ps qu ça c'est ça en fait cette année
le concours a été repris par divers
étudiants ou anciens étudiants qui
appartient à des associations
différentes notamment juris tribunes
donc les juristes la d8 donc
l'association des étudiants de l'école
d'ingénieurs ou par exemple intéresser
aux qui est une fédération étudiante
alors si on parle de l'éloquence et la
capacité à s'exprimer devant une
assemblée un auditoire l'attitude que
l'on va adopter les gestes la prestance
la voit sa capacité aussi peut-être à
faire preuve d'humour
l'éloquence regroupe plein de domaines
c'est tout ça éloquence et ça c'est
aussi suscité l'intérêt sûr que là par
exemple demain pendant la finale les
étudiants vont devoir parler devant plus
d'une centaine de personnes il faut
réussir à captiver son public
parce que le spectacle va durer pendant
plus d'une heure et demie donc par
exemple le candidat qui a passé 7e
il va être devant le public qui est là
depuis plus d'une heure d'accord il faut
réussir à capter l'attention et à le
garder
donc effectivement l'humour est un bon
moyen vous le disais il vit bien sûr
après les études pourquoi l'éloquence
est-elle nécessaire dans le monde du
travail aujourd'hui
alors ça permet de se faire de se faire
comprendre par d'onde parce que
notamment les gens n'ont pas la même
perception
il faut apprendre à parler à différentes
personnes donc c'est l'éloquence est un
bon moyen de vaincre sa timidité et
d'avoir un vocabulaire assez variés
d'être capable de s'exprimer devant un
auditoire différents mais justement
j'imagine aussi l'idée de ce concours
c'est dire à ces personnes timides
qu'elles peuvent se surpasser
s'améliorer en participant ce genre de
concours si ça a beaucoup de candidats
se sont inscrits ou simplement pour se
surpasser parce que c'est un défi
personnel
certains sont arrivés en finale donc
c'est une belle surprise pour eux on
vous l'avait dit 60 candidats candidats
ont participé à cette deuxième édition
du concours d'éloquence 10 seront en
lice demain pour cette finale ils ont
été choisis sur des
les épreuves de présélection des
présélections avec des jurys en interne
à l'université et demain pour la grande
finale est un jeu et de professionnels
de l'éloquence nous en des directeurs
artistiques de compagnies de théâtre
nous avons des directeurs de librairies
nous avons des journalistes voilà des
comédiens également d'accord un jury de
professionnels ordi finalistes donc
allez je vais des cités luther millan
sarah gamme au raïs achats thiollet et
bintou camara zara séidou de max
courtinat marianne big peau etienne
perrin manon jamais jean guillaume
philippe de saint julien et hugo jarry
je vais reprendre au soudan un instant
cette question d'abord comment ils ont
été accompagnés pour préparer cette
finale
les étudiants les étudiants cette année
c'est la nouveauté on est accompagné par
la compagnie les tisseurs de songes qui
est une compagnie théâtrale dont le
directeur artistique fait partie du jury
de la finale demain et ils ont eu la
chance je pense d'avoir un accompagnant
un accompagnement avec un comédien
professionnel sur justement la capacité
à s'exprimer le regard la gestuelle le
souffle un certain nombre de choses
comment ça va se passer demain
concrètement face à ce jury de
professionnels du coup et face au public
qui va venir alors les dix candidats
vont s'enchaîner et le jury a tout
simplement une grille de notation avec
différents critères non comme je disais
la parole la gestuelle le souffle à
tonalité de la voix
un certain nombre d'autres critères en
plusieurs sujets ont été proposés pour
ce deuxième concours d'éloquence
quelques exemples ressortons propre d'un
bain de foule
pourquoi le mot cours est il plus long
que le mot long si un homme est tué dans
l'espace est ce un crime sans gravité
voilà multitude de sujets comment on
répond à de telles questions
alors je pense qu'il faut il ya
certaines personnes qui prennent le
sujet au premier degré d'autres non
l'objectif de ce concours c'est aussi de
ne pas se prendre au sérieux
spécialement il ya deux types de
concours y avait concours de plaidoirie
où vraiment défend une idée pur et dur
là concours d'éloquence nous on part sur
des sujets assez drôle qui se base par
un petit trait d'humour règne dans le
sujet ça permet justement d'aller un peu
plus loin
non pas forcément se prendre au sérieux
la gagnante de l'année dernière a fait
un mélange d'humour et un mélange de
combat personnel sur droits des femmes
ça a marché à la guerre mais c'est des
étudiants tiennent de plusieurs filières
dont on peut se dire un concours
d'éloquence ça va va jouer en faveur des
étudiants en droit est ce que la coc au
vert oui à toutes les filières c'est
vraiment verra tout le monde l'an passé
c'est une juriste qui a gagné le 2e prix
c'était un étudiant de sciences
politiques
et le troisième c'est un étudiant
ingénieur donc c'est vraiment des
étudiants de diverses the horizon et
même un ingénieur qui est pourtant
scientifique pur et dur c'est pas
quelqu'un qui bavent d'air son pc ça
peut être quelqu'un qui peut s'exprimer
devant un public et à la clé pour le
vainqueur c'est de participer
dans le jury des autres éditions les
précédents des éditions suivantes pardon
entre autres il ya aussi un beau prix
l'année dernière c'était un ordinateur
portable à plus de 1000 euros donc c'est
d'accord voilà il ya c'est quand même
une belle récompense
une dernière question vos espérances
pour pour demain pour cette finale que
ça se passe bien qu'ils aient beaucoup
de public parce que c'est ça aussi qui
fait le spectacle
donc c'est bien entendu ouvert au public
et que les candidats se lâche c'est le
plus important
merci anthony la mode d'avoir été avec
nous parce qu'à vous créateur du
concours d'éloquence de l'ue vs q la
finale de la deuxième édition se tient
demain à 20 heures à l'amphi diderot
bâtiment d'alembert à guyancourt
l'entrée est libre et pour plus d'infos
je vous invite à vous rendre sur la page
facebook de l'événement qui s'affiche en
bas de l'écran un passage piéton en
trois dimensions la commune de chevreuse
vient d'installer ce nouveau dispositif
rue de rambouillet il utilise l illusion
d'optique et donne l'impression d'un
obstacle devant soi objectifs de
sécurité routière derrière le passage
piéton doit inciter les automobilistes à
ralentir dans cette zone en centre ville
chevreuse qui a déjà équipé de lumière
bleue une dizaine de ses passages
piétons une dizaine d'unités
supplémentaires en sera dotée dès cette
année suite de notre dossier de la
semaine à présent sur la gendarmerie des
yvelines nous vous proposons ce soir un
reportage sur la brigade cynophile de
ben et l'un de ses membres âgés de 7 ans
fidji est une chienne malinoise unique
en ile de france
c'est la seule à pouvoir détecter à des
produits utilisés lors d'un incendie
criminel rencontre signés camille
lambert
toujours plein d'entrain pour aller
travailler fidji prend son rôle très à
coeur
aujourd'hui sur le camp militaire de ben
séance d'entraînement après qu'un
collègue est posée différents produits
s'est-elle de jouy allez on y va pas
bouger tu attends une minute quand tu
cherchais il ne faut pas plus de
quelques minutes à la malinoise pour
marquer l'emplacement voilà si fidji est
aussi enthousiaste c'est parce que pour
elle il s'agit d'un jeu et pourtant son
travail est très sérieux elle détecte
les produits utilisés lors d'un incendie
criminel
alcool à brûler white spirit ou essence
rien n'échappe à son flair quel que soit
leur état
il ya un produit qui a été brûlé un
produit qui a terrassé à l'eau est un
produit qui reste nature pourquoi ces
trois états parce que quand tu sais on a
mis le feu ben les produits ont été
brûlées donc ce qui altère et ce qu'ils
changent leur le rôdeur est sûr qu'on
peut causer aux compositions
quand les pompiers sont arrivés ça a été
lavé donc pour apprendre le chien a
travaillé sur du produit brûlé sur du
produit la lave et suite à une
intervention des pompiers et sur la
matière aminata diatta toile poissy et
trouver le produit qui n'a pas encore
été brûlés
comme elle ils sont une dizaine dans le
pays une spécialité unique en ile de
france qui vaut à fidji des opérations
régulières
cette année elle a participé à 19
interventions avec son maître une équipe
complices car la chaîne de 7 ans a
parfois ses humeurs yves est l'un des
rares à pouvoir l'amadouer et surtout la
comprendre ouf
vous devrez sur papa car oui c'est mon
chien oui je travaille avec elle c'est
pas communauté de travail parce que si
on utilise notre chien que comme un
outil de travail bas moment donné ça va
pas mal ça va pas aller donc c'est
vraiment le binôme jeu
je travaille avec elle j interprète en
langage humain ce que le chien ne
donnons langage en langage chien je
dirais elle me donne des indices en
chine ont gelé traduit en langage humain
pour que mes collègues puisse
interpréter et puisse avancer sur leur
sur leur dos un véritable duo formé
pendant 14 semaines à gramat au centre
national d'instruction cynophile de la
gendarmerie iv fidji ont été accordées
selon leur caractère ne pas mettre un
chien qui va être hyper speed 1 m qui va
être calme et l' inverse
donc on essaie d'équilibrer sur les
caractères on est la seule
administration à le faire ça marche pas
mal du tout du début de mission jusqu'à
la fin de mission il faut qu'elle
travaille avec la même motivation est le
même le même entrain un chien qui au
bout d'une minute de travail va tout
laisser tomber parce qu'il en a marre
nous ne nous intéressera pas donc le jeu
ça peut s'apprendre un chien la
persévérance au jeu c'est inné soyez là
soit il l'a pas une mission qui se
termine toujours par une récompense un
moment de jeu avec son maître fidji
devrait servir encore jusqu'à ses 12 ans
elle aura ensuite droit à une retraite
bien méritée la gendarmerie recherche
toujours des chiens pour renforcer son
équipe avant de se quitter du sport pour
notre portrait de la semaine nous
faisons la connaissance de fabien vite
originaire de saint quentin en yvelines
il a connu sa première sélection en
équipe de france de rugby des moins de
18 ans l'athlète a débuté son parcours
aux mines il st denis puis est passé par
le sky rugby nicolas landry est allé le
rencontrer
mieux la fin bien c'est bien
fabien vitse 2 m 104 kg 2 sélections en
équipe de france b moins de 18 ans ce
saint quentinois est au pôle espoir
rugby du lycée lakanal de sceaux
une structure qui permet aux élèves de
suivre un double cursus un parcours
scolaire classique et une préparation au
sport de haut niveau avec 10 à 15 heures
de rugby par semaine on a quand même des
bons horaires scolaires
on a le temps d'autres à jour d'un
programme ont fait le lycée en trois ans
donc il n'ya pas de souci là dessus on
peut choisir l'edf il ya tout à fait
normal et après justement le soir
général à la fin des cours donc vers
16h30 7 h 30 on a notre entraînement et
d'un journée à la place du sport on à la
muscu pour justement essayer de se
développer pour leur billet pour les
contacter des joueurs comme wesley
fofana ou mathieu bastareaud sont passés
par ce pôle espoir musculation
mathématiques préparation physique
philosophie ou technique individuelle
les journées sont rythmées entre les
cours et les entraînements un emploi du
temps géré par le responsable du pôle
sylvain bouttier fabien c'est quelqu'un
qui travaille beaucoup là une vraie
qualité de travail et de sérieux
et il prend ensemble l'ensemble des
paramètres de la performance en faisant
attention à son sommeil son alimentation
et à travailler de manière régulière
après l'entraînement fabien revient au
lycée durant la semaine il est nourri et
logé au sein de l'établissement
c'est seulement le week-end qu'il rentre
chez lui à maurepas ses parents
l'accompagnent dans son projet grâce à
eux fabien a rencontré le rugby à l'âge
de 4 ans lors d'une journée portes
ouvertes au club du mesnil-saint-denis
c'était très très axé fait en petit donc
c'est tout ce qui est fun je pense cette
décharge d'énergie qui ma femme qui m'a
fait plaisir qui m'a je sentais que
j'étais dans l'eau et en fait des
tout-petits je sentais que ça ça me
plaisait vendre si c'était ma toute
première médaille avec le mini samedi
c'était le tournoi des géants c'était en
bon on m'a remis cette médaille non pas
parce que j'étais bon parce qu'on a
gagné c'est juste parce que j'étais le
plus jeune joueur du département en 2012
il rejoint l'équipe de saint quentin en
yvelines rugby un club où il garde de
très bons souvenirs à 15 ans lors d'une
finale régionale il est repéré par un
entraîneur de massy pour rejoindre ce
club professionnel après plusieurs tests
physiques il réussit son entrée au pôle
espoir
aujourd'hui son rêve est en train de se
réaliser ils préparent pour la deuxième
fois ses affaires pour aller au centre
d'entraînement de l'équipe de france à
marcoussis
soit vous présenter son paix porté à
faire qui représente le pays
la sélection france b moins de 18 ans
prépare le championnat d'europe une
compétition qui se déroule du 25 au 31
mars en pologne et fabien a déjà des
responsabilités dans l'équipe bas dans
l'équipe il est il est notamment
d'entraîneur de touche
celui qui annonce les zones de sauce et
celui qu'annonce quel joueur va sauter
et pour ça il est très précieux et
beaucoup même aussi évidemment il est
encore dans une phase d'apprentissage
la première étape de ce jeune saint
quentinois pour devenir peut-être un
jour un grand du quinze de france
un portrait assigner nicolas landry et
fabien vite ce qui a marqué un essai
dimanche dernier lors de la victoire de
l'équipe de france b des moins de 18 ans
face à la roumanie succès soixante sept
à huit les bleus sont transcon engagé à
demain dans les demi finales du
championnat d'europe face à l'espagne
coup d'envoi midi et fabien vite sein
qui ne devrait pas débuter cette
rencontre
c'est la fin de ce journal merci de
l'avoir suivi à suivre sur notre antenne
un nouveau numéro de mode d'emploi
présentées par aurélia rose et ce
journal vous pouvez bien sûr le
retrouver en replay sur notre site
internet et notre application mobile tv
60,18 belle soirée à tous
[Musique]